como sería el proceso para elegir al
nuevo líder del partido conservador y
cuánto tiempo puede tomar elegirlo
bueno este sin lugar a dudas el partido
conservador va a intentar por todos los
modos de lograr un proceso que sea
expedito y rápido porque mientras no se
elija a un nuevo primer ministro pues
evidentemente se sigue dañando las bases
del propio partido conservador ya se
anunció lo anunció el propio boris
johnson que la próxima semana se estaría
anunciando este calendario y por los
ánimos que existen y por los dichos que
que también se han dado por los propios
conservadores nos estaríamos pensando
que los tiempos se acortarán lo más
posible precisamente para dar
certidumbre no solamente al partido
conservador como fuerza política pero
también para dar certidumbre a los
ciudadanos británicos en el sentido de
que el gobierno está funcionando y está
trabajando precisamente para los
británicos
dámaso ante esta debilidad digamos del
partido conservador británico cómo queda
el partido laborista digamos cuánto
tiempo tiene que pasar y qué tiene que
ocurrir en reino unido- para que la
balanza se voltee de alguna manera si
realmente el partido laborista de unas
elecciones generales se pudiera llegar
al poder en reino unido- estamos lejos o
cerca de un escenario como el que le
planteo ahora
bueno en realidad
precisamente la idea de que los propios
miembros del partido conservador
llamen y pongan a un primer ministro nos
hablan de la fuerza y de la llegamos
tradición constitucional que existe en
ese país parte partido conservador
continúe no va a ser una elección
general y al propio boris johnson se
ufanaba precisamente el día de ayer de
que deberían de ya enterrar estos
asuntos y que él iba a encabezar y a
ganar las próximas elecciones generales
sin lugar a dudas todos estos escándalos
de alguna manera
debilitado los fundamentos del propio
partido conservador y era algo que el
propio partido conservador pidió con
toda claridad y por eso impulsó este
digamos caída estrepitosa de su primer
ministro boris johnson en el partido
laboral en todos estos días en sus
discursos precisamente en el parlamento
pues ha hecho el juego de esta leña y
precisamente ha usado a el partido a
través de las conversaciones
boris johnson y ha ganado puntos pero
aún sigue siendo el tiempo del partido
conservador cumplirá con su mandato
constitucional cuando haya pérdida de
confianza pues evidentemente se están
llamando a estas elecciones generales
que de cualquier manera tienen su propio
tiempo pero ahorita por lo que vemos el
partido conservador pues va a continuar
con lo que le corresponde al nombrar a
un primer ministro en sustitución de
bolivia y quiero hacer un planteamiento
y luego digamos como como lo podemos
analizar por johnson siempre ha sido
polémico boris johnson siempre ha sido
acusado por alguno que otro motivo el
incluso fue votado por estos mismos
parlamentarios que ahora lo quieren
sacar del cargo de primer ministro mejor
dicho ya le pidieron la renuncia y lo
sacaron del cargo de primer ministro
entonces porque el partido conservador
conociendo este personaje de boris
johnson conociendo los escándalos lo
votó y luego le pidió la renuncia como
también lo estábamos comentando al
principio cuando comentábamos la prensa
británica la prensa británica también
señala que boris johnson le dijo al
partido conservador ustedes mismos me
votaron sabiendo cómo era yo y ahora me
hacen esto como un poco decepcionado
porque por qué pasó esto digamos que no
era algo impredecible ya sabían quién
era boris johnson
sin lugar a dudas ya se vio en general
boris johnson pero también sabían de la
fuerza política popularidad que tenía
vor y johnson en ese momento y como bien
se ha notado pues él fue uno de los
mayores promotores precisamente del
break sí y como ya era la voluntad para
que el referéndum del pueblo británico
pues lo que se requería era precisamente
este líder que pudiera dar certeza en
esta en éste brachet cuando la propia ex
primera ministra teresa made pues tuvo
fracaso tras fracaso también tuvo su
propia moción de censura que la cual
solventó pero que al poco tiempo tuvo
también que renunciar evidentemente para
dar paso a la llegada de boris johnson
aquí lo que tenemos entonces es este
líder carismático y que prometió una
salida digamos éste al break sí y por
eso era que era
el candidato digamos este más idóneo en
ese momento político si bien yo creo
hubo malos cálculos en cuanto a su
comportamiento ya como primer ministro
que sabemos debe de honrar la
investidura y que en este caso de boris
johnson pues siguió actuando como
siempre había actuando lo que él comenta
pues es una justificación hasta cierto
punto de un tanto absurda al decir sí ya
me conocían es como cuando uno llega a
la fiesta de promoción como sois para
que no invitan entonces es cómo
justificarse a sí mismo y que entra en
su propio discurso ya usar algunos
miembros del partido conservador de ser
esta manada precisamente también de
salir todos en estampida no lo cual
evidentemente pues no con el gusto de
los conservadores pero nos habla de su
personalidad nos habla de que es
contestatario nos habla de que no siguen
las reglas pero también ratifica su
personalidad como un hombre que se ha
construido que dice muchas mentiras
psicólogos de reconocer que todo esto es
precisamente lo que el partido
conservador antes de que se siguiera
minando aún más la confianza y
destruyendo al propio partido y
debilitando el propio gobierno es que se
decidió cuando tenemos un año un poco
menos desde la primera moción de
continuar con este proceso y empujar
empujar hasta finalmente lograr sacarlo
si es la primera magistratura